thanks to google for sponsoring a
portion of today's video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fascinating
truly astonishing
this this could rewrite everything we
know about egyptian society the world
has to know
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that goes on weekly
archaeological digs to look for that
buried lore now today we're doing
something a little bit different we're
taking the script and throwing it out
the window you see normally when we do a
lore theory they all build off the
previous videos in the series like a
wobbly jenga stack that way bit by bit
piece by piece we get closer to the
truth and if something's wrong well we
go back and course correct before moving
on from there but what if someone else
has it all figured out what if we are so
completely off base that that already
wobbly stack of lore is also built on
like i don't know rubber band legs well
an earthquake is going on i am talking
about bad theories friends i mean it's
not like we've ever had any of those
before but seriously there's always more
than one way to analyze a franchise and
kanepixel's back rooms is the perfect
example of this now in case you don't
know the back backrooms is a massively
popular analog horror web series found
right here on youtube created by the
visual effects artist kane pixels it's
all about a creepy alternate dimension
of endless office hallways that people
keep no clipping into and then getting
trapped in as well as the scientific
research company async who keeps trying
to figure out what the back rooms are
all about right now our working lore
theory is that the world of the back
rooms is actually one big simulation
async's experiments have broken part of
the game engine that's running said
simulation thereby allowing people to no
clip into areas with cut content or
unused ideas and because they've broken
it now everything is glitched putting
the world in danger but you see ours
isn't the only popular theory that's
been floating around for the series in
the fan community there's been another
very popular solution to what we see
throughout these uploads see several
popular fan theories have made a
connection between kane pixels as back
rooms and ancient egyptian mythology
yeah you heard that one right ancient
egypt complete with mummies and anubis
in the field of reeds if that sounds
wild to you well you're not alone it did
to me too on a surface level the yellow
hallways of the back rooms don't really
seem like they'd share all that much of
anything in common with the shifting
sands of ancient egypt and yet there's a
community of theorists out there who
appear to have found a surprising number
of parallels between the two so that's
why we're here to review their evidence
and go further give more and ultimately
render a verdict are the back rooms
secretly connected to ancient egypt
ladies and gentlemen strap in it's morty
time leave your theories in the comments
below
i'll pick my favorites in the next
episode of morty
so the oldest example i could find is
someone calling out the potential
backroom's egypt connection was this
reddit thread by alex mijo was taken on
march 23 2022 given the flurry of posts
in the aftermath of kane's first video
though i may have missed something
earlier so apologies if i did since that
first post though a ton of other
theorists have flooded in to analyze the
connections the most in-depth example is
this massive six-page analysis from zach
gardner on the entire backroom storyline
now this thread is long so i'm just
gonna touch on the highlights here first
and most importantly the name kv-31 in
the back rooms kv-31 is the project
designation that async gives to their
low proximity magnetic distortion system
aka their portal into the back rooms at
first kv-31 might just seem like a
couple of random letters and numbers
that got slapped together but it
actually shares its name with a real
world location a tomb in egypt's valley
of the kings also named kv-31 hmm
interesting let's dive deeper literally
the topmost shaft of this tomb was
discovered all the way back in october
of 1817 but the rest of the complex
remained undiscovered until about 2010.
then in january that year archaeologists
discovered that the complex actually
went much deeper than they first
believed now just on a surface level
that already seems somewhat similar to
the back rooms right our world exists on
top of an undiscovered tomb which
remained undisturbed for thousands of
years exactly how the back rooms was
underneath the real world until async's
discovery egyptologists were also
shocked to discover that the kv-31 tomb
kept going down deeper than they
initially expected there were hidden
layers new floors to unearth as you got
deeper exactly what we see async
uncovering in the back rooms but the
connections between the two go beyond
merely the name and the general idea of
secret tomb go down as archaeologists
worked their way through the kv-31 tomb
they discovered the remains of five
mummies from egypt's 18th dynasty and
now look at the back rooms how many
missing persons posters are we shown
five and when we do happen to find one
of those bodies buried in the back rooms
it appears dehydrated dry and leathery
kinda like the remains of a mummified
person in an ancient egyptian tomb and
that's not all the mummies that were
found in kv-31 were so mangled that they
were missing limbs and unidentifiable
just like the victims of the bacteria
monster that we see in kane's series on
another note researchers of kv-31
installed a metal door over the shaft
during the excavation to prevent any
unwelcome intruders from entering the
tomb this is very similar to how we see
async erect a metal barrier between
their control room and the back rooms
preventing people from getting in while
also preventing any undead monsters from
possibly getting out spinning the doors
by the way other reddit users have
pointed out that the doors for async's
portal look awfully similar to the fall
stores that can be found in egyptian
tombs these fall stores are carvings or
paintings that are meant to be artistic
representations of a door that acted as
a threshold between the worlds for the
living and the dead these were meant to
be doors through which the spirits of
the dead could pass from the earth to
the afterlife given how deadly the
backrooms have proven so far for anyone
who no clips in let's just say demand
would be high for anything helping guide
dead spirits in fact the entire
backroom's idea bears a striking
resemblance to the egyptian concept of
the duat or the egyptian afterlife
according to egyptologist john h taylor
the content for the duat drew directly
from what egyptians knew in their
day-to-day life realistic features like
rivers fields caverns and islands while
also incorporating more fantastical
imagery like lakes of fire turquoise
trees and walls of iron and while the
back rooms isn't drawing from natural
features like rivers and caverns it is
drawing from everyday mundane things
that we're all familiar with ugly
wallpaper fluorescent lights wet
carpeting it also takes the normal and
makes it abnormal kind of like the field
of reeds and while no we haven't yet
seen anything as outright fantastical as
a lake of fire we have seen farm houses
hidden inside the walls giant chairs and
homes full of backwards road signs all
things that we're used to seeing in our
day-to-day lives but combined with other
ideas that they shouldn't be mixed with
so that's pretty much the main points
the fan created back rooms is actually
egypt theory what's my take on it well
before we get to that let's pause for a
moment to thank our sponsor for this
portion of today's video google have you
noticed that google recently added all
these little badges across search maps
and shopping to let you know at a glance
that you're supporting diversely owned
local businesses because honestly if i
hadn't been sponsored by them i wouldn't
have and you know what i love it i am so
glad that they've partnered with me to
tell you about this because i think it's
an awesome new tool that more people
should be aware of google has always
been about sorting the world's
information right well these new badges
empower you with the information that
you need to support businesses that fit
with your unique set of values suddenly
identifying women black latino and
veteran owned businesses is super simple
it's literally at a glance and this is
just the beginning of how google plans
to support local communities they've
also made it easy for businesses on
google search maps and shopping to mark
themselves as safe for people all across
the lgbtq spectrum that means that if
you're looking for a gender neutral
bathroom a transgender friendly bar or
you just want to support lgbtq friendly
businesses you can now quickly identify
those places our team is incredibly
diverse even though all you tend to see
is me in front of the camera we have
people from an entire spectrum of
different backgrounds as a result we see
firsthand how important this push
towards inclusion is everyone deserves a
place where they're accepted where they
can be themselves personally i want to
live in a world that's made for everyone
and features like this are a massive
step in that direction hopefully one day
we'll get to a place in society where
labels like this aren't necessary and
everyone is just like woo let's all
succeed together but until then google
is doing its best to make that
information as accessible as possible if
you want to find out more about how
google's helping to build that world
where everyone is welcome and everyone
belongs you can find out more at
belonging.google.com thanks again to
google for sponsoring that portion of
the video and now let's no clip back
into the back rooms haven't laid out all
the evidence what do you think seriously
let me know down in the comments i'd
love to have your thoughts on this
theory because here's the way i see it
i'm not buying it i love a good off the
wall theory and there have been plenty
of times where i've been known to
stretch real hard to get some evidence
but looking at the whole egypt
connection thing what's here is
circumstantial at best and even worse
doesn't really add up to all that much
let's start here with the biggie the
point to me that's the most compelling
the name kv-31 yes the fact that the
async project name and this tomb in
egypt line up is a fascinating
coincidence but we just don't have
enough evidence to call it anything
beyond that first of all kv-31 is an
entirely unremarkable tomb it's not very
big like the seemingly endless back
rooms and it didn't contribute anything
significant to egyptian archaeology but
more importantly there are hundreds of
tombs all around egypt it's easy to hear
a phrase like ancient egyptian tomb and
think something grand and mysterious
like the pyramids but in reality they
were just like fancy basements for
burials when i visited egypt 10 years
ago i went to a few that were literally
in the middle of some guy's backyard no
joke we in the west have this mystique
and allure attached to egyptian tombs
but they're more common than the media
would have you believe going back to
kv-31 the kv stands for valley of the
kings it's on the west bank of the nile
right across from luxor and in this one
area alone there are roughly 63 numbered
tombs kv-01 all the way through kv-63 if
kanan picked any kv number between 1 and
63 this exact same argument could have
been made it seems far more likely to me
that kane either came up with a cool
sci-fi sounding collection of letters
and numbers that just so happened to
coincide with an obscure dig site in
egypt or he knew about the numbering
system in the valley of the kings
thought it sounded cool and used it for
async's project name with little thought
beyond that trust me guys i get it i've
been there i see a weird world building
detail like that in the franchise that i
love and want to theorize about and so i
try and reverse engineer it i search
kv31 to see what comes up and boom first
result egyptian ii from there i would
try to look for what else i could add to
the theory what other connections i
could make that could be added to that
stack of jenga blocks i get why people
would want to go down this rabbit hole
cause i would do the exact same thing so
let's keep going to get a sense of how
stable the rest of the evidence is let's
look at the so-called connections
between all the doors shall we the
archaeologists in charge of excavating
kv-31 sealed the tomb off using a metal
door just like async seals off the
entrance to the back rooms using a metal
door sure that's a connection of sorts
but probably doesn't mean all that much
of anything it's far more likely that
the metal doors were chosen in both
circumstances because they're common
building materials that provide strong
protection that is just what happens
when you're trying to build a secure
door in modern times and the idea that
async's portal looks like an egyptian
false store i mean they're both
multi-tiered rectangular entrance ways
but that's because they're doors more
importantly though the theorists that
are drawing the connection here overlook
a major point the false part of the
egyptian full store they're fake they
were etchings used to simulate real
doors kane's design for the back room's
door meanwhile appears to be entirely
functional there's the main entryway and
it's surrounded by cabinets that appear
to have the necessary wires and
electronics to make the main door
function this comparison also ignores
that false door carvings were typically
taller and thinner while kane's design
is short and squat as for the five
mummies found within the kv-31 tomb
compared to the five missing people that
we see called out in kane's series that
right there on the surface seems like
it'd be a really solid piece of evidence
until of course you do the research for
yourself there aren't just five missing
people that are called out in kane
series there's actually six six posters
with six different people shown in the
video missing persons as you can see
right here it's shown for a brief moment
before the entire scene fades into this
line graph but what about all the bodies
that were mangled down there in kv-31
sadly if you look into why they were so
damaged things fall apart even further
see the tomb had been thoroughly robbed
throughout its history with damage
attributed to both ancient robbers
looking for valuables and more modern
robbers stealing the body parts mummies
to sell tourists humans are great if
kv-31 was really meant to connect to the
back rooms that would imply that other
people had been exploring the hallways
before async opened the portal this
graph that we see here in missing
persons explicitly makes it clear that
cases for missing people skyrockets
after async makes contact with the back
rooms it's only after they break that
seal that no clipping begins and finally
we get to the quote unquote evidence
point about the back rooms taking modern
mundane places and twisting them into
something uncanny just like the duot
afterlife and that i say really you
think that's evidence that's just
storytelling technique 101. you know who
else found everyday objects and then
twisted them into something uncanny the
brave little toaster honey i shrunk the
kids lose clues and some tells me that
i'm not getting away with the back rooms
is secretly the sequel to blue's clues
theory so what happened here why did so
many theorists see async's project
designation kv-31 and work so hard to
connect it to the kv-31 tomb well i
don't blame them for doing so like i've
said throughout this theory it's a
fascinating coincidence and this amazing
community of theorists was doing their
best to try and put the pieces together
just to prove my point here before
deciding whether or not i thought the
connections between egypt and the back
rooms was even intentional i did a ton
of additional research to see if i could
find anything else that might strengthen
this entire theory dots that no one else
had connected yet and if i looked hard
enough yeah the dots were there but just
like everything that we've already
talked about they were just stretched
out of the bounds of reason for example
one could say that the back room's
wallpaper texture bears a passing
resemblance to a pattern of reeds
potentially another connection to the
duod but that doesn't make a ton of
sense because the field of reeds is the
paradise afterlife for egyptians rather
than the endless maze-like hell that is
the back room see when there's a mystery
where something connects in an
interesting or unusual way humans like
to seek answers our brains are hardwired
to find explanations for the unexplained
even if there aren't any answers this is
a phenomenon called pareidolia means
that people have a tendency to impose
meaningful interpretations onto random
data finding patterns where there aren't
any have you ever looked up at the
clouds and seen a face or shape within
them or it's seen those pictures of
houses that look like people that
occasionally go viral that's possible
because of pareidolia your brain is
telling you that that cloud looks like a
dog or that house is giving you the
creepy side eye not because they
actually are but because it's human
nature to see patterns within the noise
and that's what i think happened with
kv-31 and this whole nothing burger of
ancient egyptian connection a final
example here i thought that we might
have been able to connect the bacteria
monster to egyptian tombs specifically
as some sort of manifestation of the
curse of the pharaohs this was an
alleged curse cast upon anyone who broke
into an egyptian tomb it became popular
folklore after researchers mysteriously
died in the aftermath of opening king
tut's tomb though there were many
speculated causes one of the most
popular theories was that there was some
sort of ancient bacteria or pathogen
that was dormant in the tomb that was
unleashed by opening it the curse had a
massive impact on popular culture at the
time it's also worth mentioning that
more recently a pool of black goo was
discovered in a 3 000 year old
sarcophagus i mean really there has to
be a clear connection to the bacteria
monster right but here's the thing
there's no evidence or scientific
backing that the curse ever existed at
all let alone that it was caused by
bacteria instead all the deaths can be
attributed to more natural causes like
blood poisoning from a mosquito bite and
that black goo in the sarcophagus
apparently was just a mixture of stuff
used as an adhesive to keep the
sarcophagus sealed not anything harmful
to humans gotta admit i really tried to
find a genuine connection here cause the
idea that there was an additional layer
to the back rooms that it was hiding
some historical epic just beneath its
surface of ugly yellow wallpaper it's
genuinely awesome and egypt is always
cool to talk about but everything the
community pointed out can easily be
dismissed or debunked to the point that
i just don't think that there's a whole
lot there the ancient egyptian
connections were interesting
coincidences but that's all they wound
up being loyal theorists coincidences
film coincidences and
cuts
you